sound of freedom is a surprise box
office here to the summer but also this
talk about the Q a non-connection and
how much of the story actually happened
in real life
sound of Freedom begins with the
Abduction of Rocio and Miguel Too Young
on do when siblings were tricked by
human traffickers posing as a child
modeling agency meanwhile in the United
States Homeland Security investigations
agent Tim Ballard takes down pedophile
Ernst ohinski and uses him to catch
trafficker Earl Buchanan who just who
happens to be transporting Miguel
Ballard befriends Miguel and learns that
his sister is also missing after
reuniting Miguel with his father Ballard
swear that he'll find Rocio this leads
him to Colombia where he starts working
with local law enforcement officer Jorge
and Vampiro a former cartel accountant
turned child Liberator with their help
Ballard sets up a sting to catch those
responsible for kidnapping Miguel and
Rocio namely Giselle unfortunately
Ballard is forced to quit his job as an
HSI agent while doing so choosing to
fight ferocio when no one else would
while the sting itself is successful
resulting in the rescue of 54 children
Rocio is not among those saved
eventually Ballard learns that she was
sold to a revolutionary Armed Forces
leader named which translates to the
Scorpion
to take on our alacran and save Rocio
Ballard and Vampiro are forced to go
undercover as doctors with U.N vaccines
so that they can infiltrate the rebel
base in the jungle Unfortunately they
must do this without any official
support from the Colombian government
making it unlikely that they'll return
upon reaching the river Ballard is taken
by the armed forces and Vampiro is left
with Jorge fortunately Ballard is able
to convince El alakran that he is a
doctor and that he must help those who
may be sick while undercover Ballard
eventually finds Rocio who is El
alacran's personal sex slave as evening
Falls ballad infiltrates El alacran's
quarters and finds Rocio convincing her
that he's there to help her when a
drunken El alacran arrives Ballard is
forced to kill the warlord before he and
the young girl escape on foot after
dodging the armed forces and plenty of
gunfire Ballard and Rocio escape with
the help of Jorge and Vampiro Rocio is
finally reunited with a brother and
father after months apart from his own
family Ballard has completed his mission
and returns home to hold his wife and
children we see Rocio in her room
thankful to be back home
sound of Freedom features an epilogue
that shows footage of the actual Tim
Ballard and his testimony to the U.S
Senate Judiciary Committee explaining
how he helped pass laws requiring the
U.S government to cooperate with foreign
Nations during sex trafficking
investigations text on screen also
States human trafficking is a 150
billion dollar a year industry the US is
one of the top destinations for human
trafficking and is one of the top
consumers for child sex there are more
humans trapped today in slavery than at
any point in human history including
when slavery was legal millions of these
slaves are children actual figures
concerning human trafficking are hard to
come by but these statements are backed
up by some data in 2019 the guardian
reported that over 40 million people
live in modern day slavery Based on data
from the United Nations International
labor organization and the walk free
Foundation while not all of that is sex
slavery specifically that is certainly a
component of human trafficking
additionally UNICEF reports of the US
has considered one of the top
destination points for victims of child
trafficking and exploitation as a film's
credit's role actor Jim Caviezel who
plays Ballard encourages audiences to
share the movie with others saying he
hopes that this story like he says Uncle
Tom's Cabin did with legal slavery prior
to the American Civil War might spark a
resolve to help end human trafficking
once and for all
the message
God's children are no longer for sale
there's no question that the
fictionalized Tim Ballard and sound of
Freedom did the right thing by searching
for and rescuing young Rocio no one else
was coming and if he didn't do it then
no one would have but why did he have to
quit his job to pursue her rescue
couldn't he have just asked for time off
in the film Ballard and his Superior
Frost work alongside the Colombian
government to organize a raid that will
bring Giselle and the other traffickers
down but since Ballard's over budget
Mission wasn't sanctioned by the US
government Frost was forced to end it
rather than accept defeat Ballard quits
his job with his wife Catherine's
blessing to return to Colombia and see
the sting operation through
you quit your job
and you go and rescue those kids
honey not quert he would have been
forced to return to his usual HSI duties
ultimately limiting how many children he
could save with his Newfound Freedom
Ballard worked alongside the Colombian
authorities to organize the raid which
eventually leads to frost convincing the
U.S embassy in Colombia to offer their
support as well it's certainly a risky
move for Ballard to quit his consistent
job for this Mission especially with a
half dozen children at home to care for
Bert's rocio's life and freedom were
worth more to the former HSI agent than
his paycheck
the exact timeline of sound of freedom
is a bit messy since for the most part
specific time frames aren't discussed
the very beginning of the film shows the
Abduction of Miguel and Rocio which
occurs in their hometown of Tegucigalpa
Honduras from there the children are
shipped by Freight cicada heena Colombia
while a direct flight from Tegucigalpa
to Cartagena is about 11 hours traveling
by freighter would take considerably
longer Miguel and Rocio were likely on
the boat for at least a week by the time
Tim Ballard and his HSI team rescue
Miguel they believe that he's been held
captive in Tijuana Mexico after being
separated from Rocio in Colombia for
some time possibly up to three months
from there Ballard Works overtime to
find Rocio and after the sting operation
which in real life took months to plan
and execute they still haven't found her
possibly months later Ballard finds
Rocio in the Amazon jungle before
getting her back to her family how much
longer after the stingness took place is
not clear but it's obvious that she's
been gone for a while
ultimately sound of Freedom implies that
Rocio had been missing for possibly over
six months while her brother Miguel was
gone for about half of that time
before being separated Rocio gives the
necklace to Miguel this gesture gives
Miguel strength to join the abuse he
endures and allows him to remain close
to his sister despite their distance
upon being rescued by ballad Miguel
gives the agent his sister's necklace so
that he will remember that she is out
there and do something about it embedded
on the necklace is a depiction of the
chapel of Timothy or timoteo in Spanish
who was a saint and early Christian
evangelist it's followed by a possible
reference to the Bible verse 1st Timothy
6 11 Miguel sees Ballard's own first
name as a sign that he was the one God
sent to rescue them
[Music]
Ballard to save his sister upon rescuing
Rocio Ballard returns a necklace
symbolizing that she too is now
protected from such evil the real Tim
Ballard had a similar experience he said
when a young boy gave him the necklace
after his rescue Ballard's non-profit
operation Underground Railroad quotes
him as saying
to me called it luck chance coincidence
God whatever you want to call it it was
a message that necklace symbolized a
calling now to me this is what I'm
called to do this is what I'll do for
the rest of my life
the phrase sound of freedom is only
heard once in the film but it's uttered
in a powerful moment that comes back by
the film's end the first half of the
movie builds up to the sting operation
in Colombia that ends up saving numerous
children following the successful sting
operation Ballard and Vampiro watch
dozens of rescued children as they're
cared for by the authorities and
councilors brought in to help them
adjust after such a horrific experience
the children begin to sing and Vampiro
says
do that
[Applause]
sound of freedom
so the title refers to the newly
restored voice of those who've been
taken and subjected to terrible things
as a result of human trafficking the
sound returns as a film closes as noted
earlier after Ballard rescues Rocio she
too sings in her room but this time
instead of singing alone as she does at
the beginning of the film other voices
can be heard in the background singing
along with her
Angel Studios a production company
behind the film has ties to the
television series The Chosen which tells
the life story of Jesus their first
theatrical release his only son likewise
he tells the story of the biblical
patriarch Abraham so many have wondered
if sound of freedom is also a
faith-based production the real Tim
Ballard is Mormon star Jim Caviezel and
director Alejandro montevade are
Catholic but the movie itself isn't a
religious drama it's actually rated
PG-13 for violence smoking and Drug
references and some language along with
thematic reasons aside from quoting Luke
17 2 And the tagline God's children are
not for sale the movie doesn't Venture
any further into Ballard's Faith sound
of freedom is Angel Studio's second
theatrical release and assumes to have
proven that independent features can
Thrive at the box office to Grassroots
and Word of Mouth marketing strategies
undoubtedly the faith-based audience has
been invaluable in making that happen
and has certainly impacted sound of
Freedom's box office success but again
sound of freedom is not a fake race
drama in fact the movie was originally
said to be released by a fox subsidiary
before the studio was bought by the Walt
Disney Company
since the film's release many have
claimed that sound of freedom is a cute
and non-adjacent Thriller with
considerable ties to The Conspiracy
Theory but the film itself never
mentions any conspiracy theories let
alone Q Anon the Thriller was actually
completed back in 2018 shortly after q a
non and heroines started gaining
recognition in the news for the most
part the film simply highlights the very
real horrors of human trafficking and
raises awareness for the issue so why do
people think it's associated with Q Anon
it has to do with the people involved in
the film Ballard himself has promoted Q
Anon theories so too as a film star Jim
Caviezel best known for The Passion of
the Christ and Person of Interest since
2021 cavizola's expresses belief in cure
non-conspiracy theories centering around
adrenochrome a chemical compound in the
human body that Q Anon adherents believe
is harvested from trafficking children
by wealthy Elites for its supposed
de-aging properties there is no evidence
to support this Theory
the adrenochroming of children the I
mean look where we're at right now
hopefully we need your prayers
personal politics player role in the
film at all although this subject matter
of sound to Freedom child trafficking is
a main talking point of Q Anon Believers
no Q Anon theories are mentioned in the
film but Ballard and cavizo's
involvement as well as the Q Anon
Community embracing and promoting the
film has led commentators to make the
connection
sound of freedom is Loosely based on a
true story but doesn't strictly follow
the facts in an effort to tell a
compelling story while raising Awareness
on an important issue co-writer and
director Alejandro montevade embellished
Tim Ballard's real life adventures for
the big screen with Ballard's permission
of course operation triple take the raid
in Colombia that rescued more than 50
children really happened led by Ice
Homeland Security investigations and the
Colombian attorney general's special
criminal investigative unit in
collaboration with the Colombian Navy
and Coast Guard and non-profits Breaking
Chains and operation Underground
Railroad our confirms that Vampiro is
based on a real Ally of Ballard and
though he wasn't involved in operation
triple take he did lead another mission
in Colombia the same day Miguel and
Rocio are likewise based on real victims
of human trafficking although the real
child Balor dropped everything to search
for a young boy named Gary has yet to be
found the organization also said Ballard
never went into the Amazon on his own to
rescue a child nor did he kill anyone
and while a real ballad did go
undercover as a doctor and never
resulted in a child being rescued oh you
are also explains that the film
erroneously depicts child's sex
trafficking as predominantly fueled by
kidnappings while in real life many
children who end up in sex trafficking
are groomed by adults the film's
depiction of Tim's arrest of L Buchanan
is also subject to controversy as to its
accuracy while sound of Freedom does
take a strong stance against the heinous
real world issue many of its most
exciting sequences are the stuff of
Hollywood spectacle if you or someone
you know may be the victim of child
abuse please contact the child help
National child abuse hotline at 1-800
for a child
1-800-422-4453 or contact their live
chat services
thank you